Dans le métro, vous apprenez à ne regarder personne,
mais je suppose qu'il m'a vue.
Je suppose qu'il nous a tous regardés
alors que sa main passait au-dessus du détonateur.
Je me suis souvent demandée à quoi il pensait.
En particulier pendant ses dernières secondes.
Je sais que ce n'était pas personnel.
Il n'avait pas pour objectif de me tuer ou de me mutiler, moi Gill Hicks.
Il ne me connaissait pas.
Non.
Au lieu de ça, il m'a collé
une étiquette injustifiée et non-désirée.
J'étais devenue l'ennemi.
Pour lui, j'étais « l'autre »,
le « ils », opposé au « nous ».
L'étiquette « ennemi » lui a permis de nous déshumaniser.
Elle lui a permis d'appuyer sur ce bouton.
Il n'a pas été sélectif.
Vingt-six précieuses vies ont été prises rien que dans mon wagon
et j'ai failli être l'une d'entre elles.
En un battement de cil,
nous étions plongés dans une obscurité si immense
qu'elle était presque tangible ;
j'imagine que ça ressemble à patauger dans du goudron.
Nous ne savions pas que nous étions l'ennemi.
Nous n'étions que des travailleurs qui, quelques minutes auparavant,
avaient suivi l'étiquette du métro :
ne pas regarder les gens dans les yeux,
ne pas parler,
et absolument aucune conversation.
Mais à la levée des ténèbres,
nous voulions établir un contact.
Nous nous entraidions.
Nous criions nos noms,
comme si nous faisions l'appel
et attendions les réponses.
« Je suis Gill. Je suis ici.
Je suis en vie.
Ça va. »
« Je suis Gill.
Ici.
En vie.
Ça va. »
Je ne connaissais pas Alison.
Mais je l'ai écoutée se manifester régulièrement.
Je ne connaissais pas Richard.
Mais c'est important pour moi qu'il ait survécu.
Tout ce que j'ai partagé avec eux,
c'était mon prénom.
Ils ne savaient pas
que je dirigeais un département dans un entreprise de conseil en design.
Et voici mon cher attaché-case
qui a aussi survécu à cette matinée.
Ils ne savaient pas que je publiais des journaux d'architecture et de design,
que j'étais membre de la Royal Society of Arts,
que je portais du noir --
c'est toujours le cas --
que je fumais des cigarillos.
Je ne fume plus de cigarillos.
Je buvais du gin et regardais des conférences TED,
bien sûr, je n'avais jamais imaginé me tenir un jour ici,
avec des prothèses à la place des jambes,
à donner une conférence.
J'étais une jeune Australienne
qui faisait des choses extraordinaires à Londres.
Et je ne voulais pas que ça s'arrête.
J'étais si déterminée à survivre
que j'ai utilisé mon écharpe pour me garotter le haut des jambes,
j'ai fait le silence sur tout et sur tout le monde
pour me concentrer, pour m'écouter,
pour n'être guidée que par mon instinct.
J'ai diminué ma respiration.
J'ai élevé mes cuisses.
Je me suis redressée
et je me suis interdit de dormir.
J'ai tenu presque une heure,
une heure à contempler ma vie
jusqu'alors.
Peut-être aurais-je dû faire plus.
Peut-être aurais-je pu vivre plus, voir plus.
Peut-être aurais dû aller courir, danser, faire du yoga.
Mais ma priorité et mon attention allaient à mon travail.
Je vivais pour travailler.
Qui j'étais sur ma carte de visite
était important pour moi.
Mais ça n'avait pas d'importance dans ce tunnel.
Au moment où j'ai senti pour la première fois
un de mes sauveurs me toucher,
je ne pouvais pas parler,
incapable de dire un simple mot tel que « Gill ».
Je me suis abandonnée à eux.
J'avais fait tout ce que je pouvais
et, maintenant, j'étais entre leurs mains.
J'ai compris
qui était et ce qu'était vraiment l'humanité
quand j'ai vu l'étiquette nominative
qui m'a été donnée à mon entrée à l'hôpital.
Je l'ai lue :
« Personne inconnue, probablement une femme ».
Personne inconnue, probablement une femme.
Ces cinq mots étaient mon cadeau.
Ce qu'ils me disaient clairement,
c'est que ma vie était sauve
uniquement parce que j'étais un être humain.
Aucune différence ne faisait de différence
face aux mesures extraordinaires auxquelles les sauveteurs étaient prêts
pour sauver ma vie,
pour sauver autant d'inconnus que possible
et mettre en danger leurs propres vies.
Pour eux, peu importait que je sois riche ou pauvre,
la couleur de ma peau,
que je sois homme ou femme,
mon orientation sexuelle,
pour qui je votais,
si j'étais éduquée,
si j'étais croyante ou non.
Rien n'importait
à part le fait que j'étais une précieuse vie humaine.
Je me vois comme un fait vivant.
Je suis la preuve
que l'amour inconditionnel et le respect peuvent non seulement sauver
mais peuvent aussi transformer des vies.
Voici une image merveilleuse de l'un de mes sauveteurs, Andy, et moi
prise l'année dernière.
Dix ans après l'évènement,
nous voici, bras dessus bras dessous.
A travers tout ce chaos,
ma main était fermement tenue,
mon visage caressé gentiment.
Qu'ai-je ressenti ?
Je me suis sentie aimée.
Ce qui m'a protégée de la haine et du désir de vengeance,
ce qui m'a donné le courage de dire :
ça finit pour moi
avec de l'amour.
J'étais aimée.
Je crois que le potentiel d'un changement positif général
est absolument énorme
parce que je sais de quoi nous sommes capables.
Je connais la brillance de l'humanité.
Ça me laisse avec des choses auxquelles je dois réfléchir
et des questions que nous devrions tous considérer :
ce qui nous unit n'est-il pas plus fort que tout ce qui peut nous diviser ?
Faut-il une tragédie ou un désastre
pour que nous nous sentions profondément connectés, une seule espèce :
des êtres humains ?
Quand allons-nous embrasser la sagesse de notre époque
et nous élever au-delà de la tolérance
pour aller vers l'acceptation
de tous ceux qui ne sont qu'une étiquette jusqu'à ce que nous les connaissions ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)